it'd be amazing to just talk about what
it takes with the robotic arms or in
general the whole process of how to
build the life form stuff you've done in
the past maybe stuff you're doing now
how to use bacteria this kind of
synthetic biology how to grow stuff by
leveraging bacteria is there examples
from the past and yes and just take a
step back over the 10 years of the
mediated matter group which was my group
at MIT
um has sort of dedicated itself to
bio-based design would be a suitcase
word but sort of thinking about that
Synergy between nature and culture
biology and technology and we attempted
to build a suite of embodiments let's
say that they ended up in amazing
museums and amazing shows and and we
wrote patents and papers on them but
they were still n of ones again the
challenge as you say was to grow them
and we classified them into fibers
cellular solids biopolymers pigments and
in each of the examples although the
material was different sometimes we used
fibers sometimes we used silk with
silkworms and honey with bees in or comb
as the structural material with Vespers
we used synthetically engineered
bacteria to produce pigments although
the materials were different and the
hero organisms were different the
philosophy was always the same the
approach was really an approach of
computational templating
that templating allowed us to create
templates for the natural environment
where nature and Technology could
duet could dance together to create
these products so just a few examples
with uh silk Pavilion we've had a couple
of pavilions made of silk and the second
one which was the bigger one which ended
up at the Museum of Modern Art with my
friend an incredible Mentor Paolo
Antonelli that Pavilion was six meter
tall and it was produced by silkworms
and and there we had
um different types of templates there
were physical templates that were
basically just these water-soluble
meshes upon which the silkworms were
spinning and then there were
environmental templates which was a
robot basically applying a variation of
environmental conditions such as heat
and light to guide the movement of the
silkworm you're seeing so many amazing
things and I'm trying not to interrupt
you but like one of the things you've
learned by observing by doing science on
these is that the environment defines
the shape that they create or
contributes or intricately plays with
the shape to create and so like and you
get to that's one of the ways you can
get to guide their work is by defining
that environment by the way you said
hero organism which is an epic term so
that means like it's whatever is the
biological living system that's uh doing
the creation and that's what's happening
in Pharma and and biomaterials and by
the way Precision Ag and and food new
food design Technologies as people are
betting on a hero organism is the sort
of how I think of it and and and and the
hero organism is sometimes it's the palm
oil or or it's uh it's the mycelium
there's a lot of mushrooms around uh for
good and bad and and it's cellulose or
it's you know fake bananas or the the
Workhorse E coli but these hero
organisms are being vetted on as like
the
what's the one answer that solves
everything Hitchhiker's Guide 42 42 yeah
these are sort of the 42s of of you know
of the enchanted new universe and back
at MIT we said instead of betting on all
of these organisms
let's approach them as almost like
movement in a symphony and let's kind of
lean into
what we can learn from each of these
organisms in the context of building a
project in an architectural scale and
those usually were Pavilions and then
the competition of templating is the way
you guide the work of this how many did
you say 17 000 17
532 so each of these silkworms threads
are about you know one one mile
um in distance and and and they're
they're beautiful and when and just
thinking about the amount of material
you know it's a bit like thinking about
them you know the the length of
capillary
vessels that grow in your belly when
you're pregnant to feed that incredible
new life form
um it's just nature is amazing but back
to the silkworms I think I had three
months
um to build this incredible Pavilion but
um we couldn't figure out how we were
thinking of emulating the process of how
a silkworm goes about building its
incredible architecture this cocoon over
the period of 24 to 72 hours
and it builds a cocoon basically to
protect itself it's it's a beautiful
form of architecture and it uses pretty
much just two materials two chemical
compounds saracen and fibrin the saracen
is sort of the glue of of the Cocoon the
fibroid is the fiber base material of
the coconut through fibers and glue and
that's true for so many systems in
nature lots of fiber and glue and that
architecture allows them to
metamorphosize and in the process they
vary the properties of that silk thread
so it's stiffer or softer depending on
where it is in the section of the Cocoon
and so we were trying to emulate this
robotically with a 3D printer that was
six axis Kuka arm one of these baby
kookas and we're trying to emulate that
process computationally and build
something very large when one of my
students now
um a brilliant Industrial Engineer
roboticist on my team Marcus said well
you know we were just playing with those
silkworms and enjoying their presence
when we realized that
if they're placed on a desk or a
horizontal surface they will go about
creating their cocoon only the Cocoon
would be flat
because they're constantly looking for a
vertical Post in order to use that post
as an anchor to spin the Cocoon but in
the absence of that post
on surfaces that are less than 21
millimeters and flat they will spin flat
patches and we say aha
let's work with them to produce this
this Dome
as a set of flat patches and a silkworm
mind you is a is quite an egocentric
creature
um and actually the furthest you go you
move forward in evolution by natural
selection the more
um egoism you find in creatures so when
you think about termites right they the
their material sophistication is is
actually very primitive but they have
incredible ability to communicate and
connect with each other so if you think
about the entire All of Me All of nature
let's say all of living systems as like
a matrix that runs across two axes one
is material sophistication which is
terribly relevant for designers and the
other is communication
um uh the the termites Ace on
communication but their material
sophistication is crap right it's just
saliva and feces and some soil particles
that are built to create these
incredible termite Mounds at the scale
that when compared to human skyscrapers
transcend all of buildable skills uh at
least in in terms of what we have today
in architectural practice just in
relative to the size of the termite but
when you look at the silkworm
the silkworm has zero connection
communication across silkworms they were
not designed to connect and communicate
with each other they're they're sort of
a human design species because the the
uh the domesticated silk moth uh creates
the Cocoon we then produce the silk of
it and then it dies
um so the it has dysfunctional Wings it
cannot fly it's not so so and and that's
another problem that the sericulture
um industry has is why did we in the
first place author this organism four
thousand years ago that is unable to fly
and is just there
um to basically live as
um to serve a human need which is
textiles and so here we were fascinated
by the computational kind of biology
dimension of silkworms but along the way
by the way this is great I never get to
tell the full story
so much I always I'm always like people
say oh
paragraphs they're way too long and this
is wonderful this is like heaven
she drives so many good lines but but
really but we those uh those silkworms
are not yes they're not designed to be
like humans right they're not designed
to connect communicate and build things
that are bigger than themselves through
connection and communication so what
happens when you add 17 000 of them
communicating effects that's that's a
really great question what happens is
that at some point
the templating strategies and as you
said correctly there were geometrical
templating material templating
environmental templating chemical
templating if you're using pheromones to
guide the movement of bees
in the absence of a queen where you have
a robotic Queen
um but whenever you have these
templating strategies you have sort of
control over nature right the question
is is there a world in which we can move
from templating from providing these
computational
material and immaterial physical and
molecular platforms that guide nature
almost like guiding a product almost
like a gardener
um to a problem or an opportunity of
emergence where that biological organism
assumes agency by virtue of accessing
the robotic code and saying now I own
the code I get to do what I want with
this code let me show you what this
Pavilion may look like or this product
may look like and I think one of the
exciting moments for us is when we
realized that these robotic platforms
that were designed initially as
templates actually inspired if if I may
a kind of a
collaboration and cooperation between
silkworms that are not a swarm based
organism they're not like the bees and
the termites they don't work together
and they don't have you know social
orders amongst them the queen and the
drones Etc they're they're all this the
same in a way right and and here what
was so exciting for us is that these
computational and Fabrication
Technologies enable the silkworm to sort
of to to kind of hop hop from from the
branch in Ecology of of of worms to the
branch and Ecology of maybe human-like
intelligence where they could connect
and communicate by virtue of
it you know feeling or rubbing against
each other in in an area that was hotter
or colder and they were so the product
that we got at the end the variation of
density of fiber and the distribution of
the fiber and the transparency the
product at the end seems like it was
produced by a swarm silk Community but
of course it wasn't it's a bunch of
biological agents working together to
assemble this thing that's really really
fascinating to us how can technology
um
augment or enable a swarm-like behavior
and creatures that have not been
designed to work as swarms so how do you
construct a computational template from
which
uh a certain kind of thing emerges so
how can you predict what emerges I
suppose so if you can predict it it
doesn't count as emergence actually I
think
that's a deeply poetic line we can talk
about it I mean it's a bit like this
concentrated it doesn't count that's
right right speaking of emergence
an empowerment because we're constantly
moving between those as if they're
equals in on the team and one of them
Christoph shared with me a mathematical
equation for what does it mean to
empower nature and what is empowerment
in nature look like
um
and that relates to emergence and we can
go back to emergence in a few moments
but I want to I want to say it so that I
know that I've learned it
and if I've learned it I can use it
later yeah and maybe you'll figure
something out as you said of course
Kristoff is the master here but but
really
really we were thinking again what does
nature want nature wants um
nature wants to increase the information
Dimension and reduce entropy
um what do we want we kind of want the
same thing we want more but
um we want order right and this goes
back to your conversation with Joshua
that stochastic versus deterministic
languages or processes his definition or
the definition he found
um
was that an agent is empowered
if the entropy of the distribution of
all of it states it's high while the
entropy of the distribution of a single
state given a choice given an action is
low meaning it's that kind of uh
um
yeah Duality between opportunity like
starting like this and going like this
opening and closing and and this really
I think is analogous to to human
empowerment given uh infinite wide array
of choices what is the choice that you
make uh to
you know to to enable to empower uh to
provide you with with the agency that
you need and how much is that making
that choice actually control the
trajectory of the system that's really
nice so this this applies to all the
kinds of systems you're talking about
yeah and
to a human on an individual basis but or
a silk or more a b
um or a microbe a microbe that has
agency or by virtue of of of a template
um but it also applies to a community of
of organisms like the bees
um and so we've done a lot of work sort
of moving from you've asked how to grow
things so we've grown things uh using
um co-fabrication where we're digitally
fabricating with other organisms that
live across the various Kingdoms of Life
and and those were silkworms and bees
and uh and with bees
um which we've sent to outer space and
we turned healthily and they were
reproductive okay you're gonna have to
tell that story you're gonna have to
talk about the robotic queen and the
pheromones come on like
um so we've built what we called a
synthetic apiary and the synthetic
apiary was designed uh as an environment
that was a Perpetual spring environment
for the bees of Massachusetts they go in
hibernation of course during the winter
season
um and then we lose 80 percent of them
or more uh during that period we're
thinking okay what if we created this
environment where
um before you template right before you
can design with you have to design four
right you have to create this space of
mutualism space of sort of shared
connection between you and the organism
and with bees it started as the
synthetic apiary and we have proven that
that curated environment where we
designed the space with high levels of
control of temperature humidity and
light and we've proven that they were
reproductive and alive and we realized
wow this environment that we created can
help augment bees in the winter season
in any City around the world where where
bees survive and thrive in the summer
and spring seasons and could this be a
kind of a new Urban typology an
architectural typology of symbiosis of
mutualism between organisms and humans
where these are by the way the synthetic
apiary was in a co-op in you know nearby
Somerville we had you know we had robots
our team you know slept there every day
with our with our tools and machines and
we made it happen and the neighbors were
very happy and and they got to get a ton
of Honey at the end of the winter and
and those bees of course were released
into the wild at the end of the winter
Alive and Kicking so then in order to
actually experiment with with the
robotic Queen
an idea or concept we had to prove
obviously that we can create this space
for uh for bees and then after that we
had this amazing opportunity to send the
bees to space on Blue Shepherd mission
that is part of blue origin and we of
course said yes we'll take a slot we
said okay can we outdo NASA so NASA in
1982 had an experiment where they sent b
b's to to outer space the bees returned
they were not reproductive and um
and some of them died and and we thought
well is there a way in which we can
create a life support system almost like
a small mini bio lab of a queen and her
retinue
um that would be sent in this blue
origin new Shepherd Mission uh in this
one cell and and so that's if the
synthetic APO is an architectural
project in this case this second
synthetic APA was a product it was right
so from an from an architectural
controlled environment to a product
scale control environment and this bio
lab this life support system for bees
was designed to provide the bees with
all the conditions that they needed and
and we looked at that time at the
national pheromone that the queen uses
to guide the other bees and we looked at
pheromones that are associated with a b
and thinking of those pheromones being
released inside the capsules that go the
capsule that goes to outer space they
returned um back to our the media lab
roof and those bees were alive and
kicking and reproductive and you know
and they continue to create comb and and
it ended with a beautiful nature paper
that the team and I published together
we gave them gold nanoparticles and
silver nanoparticles because we were
interested if if bees recycle wax it was
known
forever that bees do not recycle the wax
and by feeding them these gold
nanoparticles we were able to prove that
um that the bees actually do recycle the
wax the reason I'm bringing this forward
is because
we don't view ourselves as designers of
consumable products and and
Architectural environments only but we
love that moment where these
Technologies and by the way every one of
these projects that we created
involve the creation of a new technology
whether it be a glass printer or the
spinning robot or
or the life support system for for the
bee Colony they all involved a
technology that was associated with the
the project and I never ever ever want
to let that part go because I love love
technology so much
um and but but also another element of
this is it always these projects if
they're great they reveal new knowledge
about or new science about
um the topic that that you're
investigating be it you know
silkworms or or bees or or glass that's
why I say I always tell my team it
should be at MoMA and the cover of
nature science at the same time we don't
separate between the art and the science
it's it's it's it's one of the same